the CEO of blackrock's talking about
Bitcoin loving on bitcoin right now the
total great tracking mechanism that's
what he said no he didn't say tracking
mechanism he just said I I have a lot of
Hope for the future we at BlackRock we
we have hope is one of our main our main
tenants and uh I just want to talk about
Bitcoin because uh it's a hedge against
in case uh I'm gonna stop talking now he
didn't want to like be like well just in
case
yeah I heard that yep yeah I feel like
anything that gives BlackRock hope we
should all just be very wary oh yeah if
the CEO BlackRock is saying I care about
Hope and here's Bitcoin I think that
he's telling you if you want to have
hope for the future to get that I don't
know but that's what it feels like is
he's like this is my here's my my get
out of jail free pass do you want it
yeah because I'm talking about Bitcoin
right now because we are BlackRock this
is a lot like what I think uh Alex Jones
was talking about on the culture War
podcast a few months ago that these
these Elites set a bunch of bear traps
publicly announce where they are and
then sit back and wait